good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I am joined by Rachel
O'Brian say welcome to the show thanks
for having me and so long since we've
seen you I know I can't believe I made
it here with my lyft driver getting in a
fistfight right that's so crazy and I
was really screaming I'm gonna be late
for the morning toast out the window at
him and did they respect that no they
did not care no respect did not care and
then did not apologize when he got back
in the car that is so crazy that's New
York for you though I'm not prepared for
that no I'm not prepared if that ever
happened to you yeah there's been times
where like either you got into an
accident or they like start you know
yelling on each other and then I just
like wait in the car I'm like so lazy
anything to not get out of the car oh
yeah no I didn't get out of the car cuz
I needed to get here right no but it's
always I'm still here it'll pass some
point but I was screaming at them I was
going to have okay
that's braver than me I would look like
literally just sit there been like keep
running the meter but seriously take
advantage of me totally well welcome to
New York how are you enjoying your stay
so good we had a great show last night
we have a show tonight too Oh where's
your show tonight
West Side comedy club that is so fun
yeah there's so I think a few tickets
available Oh fun being a comedian is so
brave so thank you for your service
thank you I mean Claudia's doing it
nobody is doing u2 and I tell her every
day like I just think it's like one of
the hardest jobs yeah mentally and
physically if you're Tori how does she
how is she handling I'd like to talk to
her a little bit about it on Instagram
but like ish did she get real nervous
before actually she's like such a pres
she's like such a natural and she's like
born for it and she is like such an
outgoing personality it suits her but
like for someone so you must be like so
extra burden because I can't imagine
like I like really not I really don't
fall into the category of like well no
there's a lot of comedians that aren't
like super true like like how do they
get on stage like you need like balls of
steel I guess so but I also think that
for a lot of comedians like they're most
comfortable when they're on stage that's
when they're the most on and then
otherwise like I'm more of an observer
actually yeah interesting and you take a
sketch comedy very serious very very
seriously Ariana did my podcast recently
and we talked about that it was I was
like doing quickfire questions with her
like you know pancakes or waffles or
whatever and then I
slipped it or they go do you think I'm
funny she was like sorry I'm still the
ricean she's actually really sweet yeah
I'm glad that everybody like loved her I
think she's great I'm glad everyone's
getting along yeah like it was time and
she was like I was on both sides and now
we all have like a common enemy or
everyone does which is James we'll get
into all the Vanderpump world up
afterwards I did not watch this week's
episode you guys I'm so sorry I'm still
on like catching up on Game of Thrones
and that's my whole world right now so
maybe next week we could talk about it's
so left out on Game of Thrones it's
never too late no I think it's too late
now
there's too much to binge but like I
should have been it's the last season
and then everyone's already gonna be
talking about it it'll be the great show
to binge once it's over and like maybe
in a year like whenever anyone needs to
show to binge like if you're like having
surgery or like you have a lot of
downtime or you're have a baby and
you're just home and you want to show to
binge
okay just through baby it they're a bad
boyfriend those are the times when like
anyone is ever like really looking for
shows to binge like when they just had a
baby so therefore they or they're on bed
rest so they've had surgery eat true
good so if you ever have surgery or have
a baby that's a good time to binge aim
of Thrones and the whole season will be
there for you and then you'll just be
frustrated that you didn't watch it like
live with the world and going good I'm
gonna like want to talk about it with
people they're gonna be like that was
ten years ago right like no totally like
when I watch every episode I like go on
Twitter and like see what the theories
are but you won't be able to have that
experience but it's still it's still
good stuff do you watch the Oh a No so
good really yeah what's it about but
like with the Oilers it's it's very it's
too hard to explain it's like I don't
even know if it falls into the category
of drama or sci-fi or what it's yeah
it's like paranormal stuff kind of I
said like is it like spooky I don't like
cars it's not horror it I mean you can
get a little freaked out but it's not
it's not spooky like that it's yeah and
there's only two seasons so you can
catch up on that okay yeah I don't know
I think that's super adventurous it's
really even crazy that I started getting
Thrones when I did
yeah just like god I got it at the right
time yeah I feel like an early investor
that's great yeah it's I feel like with
podcasting people are like how was your
podcast successful I'm like I think I
just got in before everyone had a pod no
I mean in there I'm not special
in lifetime
is everything and like what's the I feel
like I'm always quoting Andy Warhol or
the other one the one not Andy Warhol
the one who makes movies you know does
he like look like you yeah
to me they they can't see anywhere else
the artist Oh a Woody Allen what do you
look like I always confuse them and so
it was either one of them who said like
98% is just like showing up the other 2%
is luck I don't know which person said
that but I've heard it but I know it was
you're gonna know it's gonna be like
Winston Churchill I'm glad that you knew
that it was what yelling because they're
so similar I need to look at pictures of
each of them side by side but um anyways
yeah no totally agrees house podcast
life it's great it's great I love it
I don't know stand up I'm doing a lot
more of than podcasting if it makes
sense like I feel like that's just been
such a main focus right now yeah touring
like a lot yeah who's been like your
favorite guest on your podcast um I
actually just had Jax on recently and he
was really funny he's so funny I love
him here at the toast
he's like I don't know how it's possible
but he's really like a changed person
like I didn't he what really cares about
like his friends and stuff like I I
truly believe that like he regrets the
way he treated like me and Stassi and
really every girl he's ever dated and
and I think that when we showed up for
his dad's funeral it was like he was
kind of like these people are my friend
and so he's just like like he was
tweeting I didn't even ask him - he was
like tweeting telling people to like go
see me on my tour and stuff I'm like
it's so it's so nice yeah so supportive
yes speaking of supportive stassi's book
came out yesterday you know I'm going on
the fighting today you should go oh my
god I wonder like I'm a big fan I
actually pre-ordered it so I'm so
excited like to read it I love reading
like a celebrity reality star I don't
know if it's a tell-all our biography or
whatever it isn't excited to consume I
do a book I loved when I was younger was
Nicole Richie's book really I have two
she's funny
really yes she is yeah see have you read
Sassy's books I haven't I mean I helped
her like a little bit along the way she
would just call like she'd call a lot of
us and like ask us if we remembered
certain things and stuff and I guess I'm
in the book it's exciting have you heard
is it like juicy uh yeah I think I think
it's
I think it's like it's it's fun it's I
don't know it's like I think she's
trying to give advices like self-help
like in a more modern yeah I ordered it
too but I think it's gonna arrive like
now like when I'm gone no same I ordered
it and I'm sure it's in my lobby but I
just never pick up my packages maybe one
day I'll get my hands on it I do that to
where I just won't open I have like
several like Amazon boxes I don't know
what's in them no I just like I can't
and there's heavy and light I think and
then we have to like break the boxes
down when you throw a mom and like I
were like doing returns for I love
online shopping at home chop any other
way but the return process
I can't if I have to print something
it's not happening yeah I do know
something that I did open before I left
the from Amazon that my mom sent me my
mom sent me GHP testing kits for my
drinks for my - what's GHB testing like
the date rape drug oh my goodness she's
expecting me to take out test strips and
put it in my drink like it's like I'm
gonna look crazy Walter White or
something are your drinks always
unattended when you're touring no
they're never like no this is a good
thing to have on hand you never know so
weird it's kinda weird but it's like if
someone sees it poking I have your
person maybe they won't mess with you
maybe that will just say it's turn it on
myself just think yeah totally okay well
we have some great stories for you today
before we launch into everything then
our prime rules everything Rachel so
without further ado here are the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
okay first story that we actually didn't
got a chance to touch on yesterday
cloudy and I did a podcast episode only
yesterday if you missed it go catch up
we recap Coachella everything good times
we've never done a podcast together like
over the phone she's always touring and
I was bringing to co-host but then we
were like we wanted to do it together so
she called in and I felt like I had a
radio show like she was a caller I
listened to that one that's why it
sounded different I was like why does
this sound yeah it was it was different
and people really seemed to enjoy it so
if we do it again we will work on
getting that audio perfected no it
didn't sound bad but it sounded like a
call-in
yeah yeah because people are saying that
on other podcasts how do you do it when
you have someone calling it like a Skype
call it's not like a video skype call
but the audio connects okay cool
and it sounded yeah very similar like
when I had Kathryn Dennis on it was a
Skype one and yeah
I love her how's she doing I haven't
talked to her in a while but I think
she's good I think she's like I saw
Naomi a couple weeks ago she was in LA
and she said that Katherine's really
happy she's like has a boyfriend she met
someone nice oh my god that's it he's a
country singer oh I did see that yeah
good for her yeah that's kind of guy
mm-hmm uh southern terms coming back
soon and I saw a premium so excited it's
one of the best shows on TV I know so
underrated I feel I haven't really
watched it since I've been friends with
them like Stassi and I like you know
we're obsessed with watching it and then
when we talked to them and made them our
friends in the show are you I just don't
like I don't want to watch them fight
and stuff like I don't like watching
Vanderpump because I'm like first of all
I see this in real life all the time
right is this banner but since you're so
close to Vanna is it the show pretty
much like a good display of like what
actually happened yes it's like I said
this is saucy that day my pockets I was
like do you think you guys fight like
this still because like it's like
conditioned like you got rewarded
basically for fighting with each other
you're like in a fairly young age like
cuz they all started the show in their
early 20s and like now it's just like
your natural homeostasis because no they
fight like that all the time like they
fight like that even after the summer
when they're done filming all the time
is there so much that goes on like
during the winter where it's like this
would make for such good TV all the time
yeah I feel like honestly the better
stuff happens off camera but they can't
follow them around all the time you know
they can that's so like that would be so
frustrating like cuz then it's like you
think I have to go through something
else
traumatic mm-hmm in order or they kind
of just make them recap it sort of are
pretty sort of pretending it happened
yes or like that's based off of that
like I remember when lava took them to
Coachella and the nba's and all that but
that wasn't filmed but they just like
talked about it a lot okay anyways love
signing an NDA and it was our first
story in some bittersweet news the
notre-dame Cathedral had a massive fire
over the weekend but now more than 700
million dollars has been raised
overnight to rebuild the notre-dame
Cathedral French president Emmanuel
macron promised to rebuild the
notre-dame Cathedral of following a
devastating fire that destroyed the
Paris landmarks fire and roof on Monday
overnight donations have been flooding
in in the hundreds of millions
as of Tuesday evening local time over
700 million euros around seven hundred
and ninety million dollars has been
raised for what is sure to be a massive
rebuilding project much of that money is
coming from some wealthy French citizens
including Salma Hayek's husband Francois
Henri pin alt who heads carrying si the
fashion company behind Gucci and
Alexander McQueen among other luxury
designers he pledged in a donation of a
hundred million euros
Bernard Arnold who heads Karen's rival
company LVMH which is the parent company
and Louboutin mo a Hennessy pledge said
he and his company would donate 200
million euros to the reconstruction this
is really amazing it's really exciting
it was so sad I think I actually like
almost cried over and I was tearing up
it's so sad I've never been there
it's amazing and I may move to Paris and
volunteer to help rebuild it cuz I love
it so much Julie I mean I'm a like like
if they're looking for a balance like if
they yeah like call me volunteer matters
totally well I don't know how much it
costs to rebuild a thing like this but
700 million euros seems like a good
place like I feel like yeah who covered
the cost maybe a little extra so I don't
know I don't know this part was like how
much like stuff that was irreplaceable
was damaged like art and well there was
I was reading there was one um hold on
let me get the exact and was the fire
caused by I don't know renovations they
were currently doing I have no idea yeah
so I read one of the Chaplin of Paris's
fire department is being hailed as a
hero for rushing into the Cathedral to
save priceless relics from the inferno
from the inferno he seemed the crown of
thorns I'm sure there was still like a
lot of stuff lost but it seems as though
there was a lot that was saved her and a
lot that was preserved as you're gonna
be there in a couple weeks it's gonna be
very strange to see it in its current
state totally and the French president
said that we will build this was a nice
quote we will rebuild Notre Dame because
is what the French expect of us it is
what our history deserves it is in the
deepest sense our destiny that's good I
know and I feel like these days you mean
you watch like you know home improvement
and they build houses overnight like
yeah it's possible that this could take
you know maybe a year they were saying
that the I thought didn't you say five
years in the article you said no wasted
five years that seems like a it could be
sure I mean I don't know
thing about construction but I feel like
it's a pretty huge it's pretty here yeah
I think it will take and they and I
think to like bring it back to its
former glory I think it's I mean like
the houses they're building on home
improvement is totally but like so I'm
just saying like things go up pretty
quickly and actually five years may trip
and Joanna Gaines wolf chippin they they
should I mean all hands on deck here you
guys yeah the Olympics are being held in
Paris in 2024 so I think that's their
goal to have it done by then and also
that'll just be like a nice thing even
if it like to have that be like the
finish unveiling right and everyone will
be in town that sounds exciting yeah
that's exciting
maybe I know that's a good that's a good
goal for me too you know it's always
looks like set realistic goals like I
finally I cut my finger last night
because um I did a cooking class like
this was my third in a boot camp session
I've been talking about it like every
night listen I heard you on the phone
because I I don't know how to cook like
I can't do anything and I'm just like
ready it would be like a little bit
healthier and just like do you think
what type of cooking gossiped healthy
cooking or zooms it was like a 101 it
was three weeks the first week was just
knife skills so all we did was chop like
veggies and then last week was meats
I'd never like handled rami before
creepy as hell
but I figured out what I do like which
is yeah boneless breast okay
cutlet like something thin yeah I don't
need all the bones and the skin this is
just funny because I cook like a lot oh
do you like it myself a fantastic oh my
god evany and then yesterday we learned
fish I was like I don't ever see myself
because you're cooking fish like in the
home but what I did learn that was
interesting is like even if you
undercook fish like it'll never like
hurt you like there's no Salmonella all
right right I didn't realize that I
thought they were I thought it was gonna
be the opposite where it's like it has
to be cooked really well
girls like you'll die but so that's good
to know so even I can't really screw it
up yeah but you just cut your finger
that's not I know I I got in charge of
making the ratatouille last night like
volunteer cuz I really wanted to learn
how to make veggies instead of the fish
because I know that they're like such a
good wife at you're doing this I know
it's just like it's it's taken me a long
time I'm really trying like you know
mature
yeah I can't order in all the time
anymore and then it's like I don't want
to order them too I just don't eat if I
want if I don't want to like and that's
not healthy either yeah I don't ever
think that food when you get you order
and even taste that good it never tastes
like it does no restaurant it's always
like a little cold
percent I feel the same way so I'm
really I'm excited about this new
chapter and we're really inspired is I
got all my registry stuff and I now I
have these nice things to cook with and
I want to be able to you are you guys
still doing keto or were you doing kiddo
yeah so I've been on enough of keto for
like almost three years now don't lose
weight
yeah I've it's easy to know but like
I'll show you a picture from a year ago
it's like not cute Claudia like it's
hilarious and it's like in at the time
you don't realize like what you look
like until you look less than that and
then someone took a photo of me on stage
last night and I was like holy [ __ ] I
think so that's a tough angle though
from the audience to this it's never
flattering no it's never that was
wearing mom jeans it was all with such a
mistake that's nice this is a super cute
after you were getting a lot of comments
on it who makes your shoes oh my god
JustFab there's like $30 well one of my
podcast sponsors and I feel like they
look like they're like Balenciaga or
some no totally they sponsor our show -
and we love just having now I'm gonna go
get those shoes so and there I'm
credibly comfortable I walked all day in
them yesterday Wow
oh my god good to know how about tips
interesting factoids so yes I love hito
these things I need to wait on keto -
the first time I ever tried it like in
college I like gained I didn't know what
I was doing I eat like so many nuts and
I gain weight like see that was that was
me cuz I already ate a lot of butter and
I was pretty sure I was up to like a
stick of butter a day I was like I can
just put butter on everything I would
melt it and pour it on things and then I
was shocked that I was gaining weight
but like you can do that but it's like
what were you put things that you were
pouring it on probably weren't as like
keto friendly as you thought maybe it's
hard to figure out yeah I don't know the
ratio cuz they say it should be like
what 70% fat oh I don't even like I
started keto when he was still called
Atkins and so I was just no carbs yeah
any like I never did my fat to protein
ratio I figured like if I could do no
carbs that's that would be good enough
and it wasn't yeah so I did it for my
wedding and anytime I mean to lose
weight I do keto but now I'm like just
trying to maintain and honestly it's not
going well yeah and so like I don't know
how to maintain weight I just either
gain or lose yeah I mean I've maintained
it for like a long time but I've been on
a steady incline I mean I eat a bagel on
the way here my cab driver whatever was
getting
and I was eating a bagel your New York
true so that's an excuse
yeah if I were traveling as much as you
I would be [ __ ] because whenever I
travel like I stick to no plan Stassi
and we're talking about this too is like
we love eating on airplanes like I'm
like give me seven tapas boxes why do
you never say I'm on an airplane like
I'm just like it's like a black hole and
it says it's like everything I've ever
known about food goes out the window and
it's not about like what's healthy or
like what's good for me it's like I need
to see to survive I mean anything that
comes my way just in case the plane goes
down I need to stock up when we went to
Coachella we were buying snacks before
the plane we bought like what we wanted
which was like baked Lay's and popcorn
whatever and then we also each bought
like Clif bars and like kind bars like
just in case like we got stranded yeah
just in case yeah right like we're like
you there was no food at Coachella right
so I don't know what that meant and
honestly like it's so it's so either so
I can't travel that much or else I was
just loose it's just so fun to eat on a
plane and just watch movies I know I
love it
I watched um Game of Thrones the whole
way and it really goes so quickly when
you have something to watch so were you
really watching I was reacting because I
was trying to get totally prepared for
the new season I didn't catch up in time
so I still watch the new episode but now
I'm still continuing my rewatch so I
have all of the facts because I feel
like I'll be able to figure it out if I
know everything I don't know do you
watch it with the subtitles on that test
so I only watch like a few of the first
season and that that's how she made me
watch it she was like you have to really
pay attention so he idles I guess oh no
I never did that I actually just really
pay attention like I don't look at my
phone that's so smart
yeah interesting little tip even though
I don't watch it no that's really
helpful okay
next story times list of 100 most
influential people of 2019 has come out
like literally as we went live so I'm
just gonna run through some of the names
and categories in the pioneers category
we have sent okay I'm not gonna read 100
people saying so I'm worried some people
that I recognize Sandra Oh she is
definitely influential because she did a
job at hosting the Golden Globes when
like honestly no one expected much uh
Christy Teegan barians lunch I feel it's
so cool
I feel like she's on this list every
year she's on some list because she
really is like so it or maybe it's like
most influential people on the internet
she's always on like yeah but she's
being considered like in flow - overall
ya know she
like time is prestigious as hell I think
it's great I love her I think she can do
no wrong um it took me a while to come
around on her um but these days I do
really like her because and not in the
way like I don't follow her Twitter
everything I feel like everyone's always
trying to like make her seem like more
obnoxious than she is when she's just
like a funny guy trying to let her lie
to herself and she's I think she cares
and she's enjoying the fruits of
celebrity yeah and I feel like if I were
in her position I would do the same
yeah totally artists Dwayne Johnson
Regina King Khaled Emilia Clarke quite
influential BTS brie Larson Joanna and
chip Gaines in tune ariana grande Mahalo
Ali Glen clothes Rami Malek Lucci de
Hurtado Ozuna of haddem dream Hampton
Richard Madden I don't know that he's so
influential he's in the new show that I
don't want to he's from theme of Thrones
and popularly the Cinderella remake but
I guess he's influential these days he's
in the show called The Bodyguard okay I
don't want it so the remake of the
Whitney Houston Kevin Costner now you
would think maybe it's be signified a
different title it's not then we have
some leaders in the political space
Nancy Pelosi Donald Trump Alexandria okz
okay zo Cortez Benjamin Netanyahu a lot
of political leaders exciting for them
icons okay this is our field Taylor
Swift looking gorgeous looking like ts7
vibes what are your thoughts on Taylor
Swift's didn't look like her I know
she's really putting out like positive
cleany vibes these days I like her and
she's got something coming on for 26
what she's dropping something no like we
don't how do you know it's for 20 says
she's posted on her Instagram I'm like a
picture and then said for 26 it's like
the most clear clue she's ever given
even though her why does it annoy me
just a tad though where it's like you it
annoys me so much you are you think so
highly of yourself that all you're gonna
do is put a date people are like oh my
god what's she doing it's like my
Claudie and I thought literally I was
getting worried when the Valerius who
cardi and I have literally fought about
this how she treats her Instagram like
The DaVinci Code and it's like up to the
Swift East like figure it out and then
she gives him no more soul of clues
except like a three legs of a chair so
426 is actually
a legitimate clue for them whereas
before it was like just seven palm trees
and it's like it's it's a photo palm
trees right that's what I was saying
like oh she's into photography how she's
feeling inspired yeah that's what I like
maybe it means nothing but now we know
something's coming for 26 and then
people were saying Kim Kardashian is
dropping her perfume on for 26 like is
she like shading her no so dumb it's so
dumb I can more icons Michelle Obama
Spike Lee Christine huazhi Ford David
Hockney Desmond Mead Lady Gaga
true icon so many I so many people who
are so iconic Titans LeBron James Gayle
King Mark Zuckerberg Tiger Woods Bob
Iger we've been talking about Bob Iger a
lot of lately because he is the head of
Disney and Disney's just like making all
these money moves and it's all Bob Iger
really they're starting a new streaming
service like in competition with Netflix
oh that's amazing
they're gonna have like all the D coms
and is it gonna be all like children no
but it's like so all Disney stuff is
also includes like ABC ESPN I'm gonna
Marvel maybe does that make sense
and then they're also partnering with
Hulu so the content - it's something to
be reckoned with Pat McGrath what am I
in tune choice it's like they left Kylie
Jenner off the list this year but they
included Pat McGrath I guess so where
she's not on it at all no there was only
room for one Beauty Titan and it went to
Pat McGrath this year I just wish she'd
like lower her prices a little bit but
other than that I'm so here for her and
then like those are the the big names
speak as it relates to this show
speaking of Lady Gaga going back to her
how did you feel about their their PDA
okay is it bothers me it's really I'm
like a pod it was like one of those
things again where was like a Taylor
Swift thing where it's like we're trying
to decipher all of this stuff but then
after I watch the Oscars performance and
then they went completely their separate
ways after their kameen what campaign
was over I kind of understood it cuz it
was like life imitating art it was like
every time they perform that song or
every time they showed up together they
were being a Lee and Jackson main like
they were really like interpret me and
like in the movie they go to the Grammys
and they're - they're married and see
they go to the Oscars and they like have
this couple year relationship and I
thought it was like I could understand
her as an artist doing it in that way
anything else makes no [ __ ] sense to
me yeah like his wife is right there
it's me he's not his wife his dating
she's so gorgeous too but like I just
like they made me uncomfortable after a
while where I'm just like oh god yeah no
after the Oscars was like peak yeah and
then I'm glad it was like totally over
babe I needed it to stop I yeah just
because it's like if it's not happen I
was jealous for that woven I forget her
name wasn't Irina Shayk yeah but if it's
not like if they're not in love and
they're not a couple then like what is
you doing what are you doing why you
just trying to like tease us like this
with an emotional roller in is there
yeah and it's all for nothing because
you're not in love so what it has to be
heard the love of the art I guess so
that's how I like rational excited in my
head but that was like such a crazy time
when like every week there was like
speculation about the two of them they
were like holding hands over her like
just sitting there like so awkward it's
so awkward Bay this was like all
unfounded because no one's whispering
about them now yeah sure and maybe it
was all for the movie like the movie
really you know took over they like
hooked up or anything I just think that
like the aggressive like PDA was weird
yeah I think there's a lot of mutual
respect there yeah but they just like
everyone I'm gonna go with art it was
art okay totally okay next story we were
just talking about a very relatable
headline coming from Anne Hathaway which
sounds like an oxymoron but it's not
Anne Hathaway I don't have a drinking
problem I have a hangover a problem same
girl and Hathaway is making it clear
that she doesn't have a drinking problem
but a hangover a problem after she
revealed in January that she'd given up
booze the Princess Diaries actress 36
explained her decision a bit further in
a new magazine interview quote I didn't
put a drink down because my drinking was
a problem I put it down because the way
I drink leads me to have hangovers and
those were the problem Hathway admitted
that her last night of drinking led to a
five-day hangover something that she
said just can't happen when she has her
three-year-old Jonathan to take care of
quote when I'm at a stage in my life
where there is enough space for me to
have a hangover I'll start drinking
again but that won't be until my kid is
out of the house she said adding her
that her decision to give up alcohol is
a personal one and that quote I don't
think drinking is bad in general it's
just the way I do it which I personally
think is
fun and awesome it's just not the kind
of fun and awesome that goes with having
a child she likes to party
no I didn't know her is a good time like
she's basically saying the way it like
she's taking shots and stuff like I have
never had a five-day angle no I've never
had a five-day over these days I'm
verging on a two-day hangovers yeah and
and it's only getting worse with age so
like I'm 26 and that's where I am when
I'm 36 I could see myself having a five
anything over like yeah I feel like I'm
looking into a crystal ball and like
this is my future yeah she said he's
getting her son's getting to an age
where he really does need me all the
times in the morning I did one school
run where I dropped him off at school I
wasn't driving but I was hungover and
that was enough for me I didn't love
that one
yeah like when I get it I mean if I got
I don't get super hungover but I imagine
when I'm 36 it's only gonna get worse
yeah and I would probably quit drinking
if it affected me that much yeah I don't
think I'll be able to drink forever like
when I have young kids because when I
drink even if I have like a small
hangover like the next morning I'm
immobile like I could barely go pee yeah
and you have to take care of another
human being I'm so like so depressing
because you also think the only way to
survive like motherhood is like drinking
yeah you know but maybe like a glass of
wine or two but that just that's always
my room then it just leads to more yeah
I mean my drinking is slowed down so
much just because your body just sort of
gets sick of it like I just sort of them
like like I don't know like you and I
think that that just happens more with
age you know yeah well like oh wait
anytime we have someone from an
umbrellas on my question is always like
how do they drink so much and not get
hungover like when they go on these
trips are like and they there requires
like filming like you can't even get a
one day hangover yes you have to work
they the Vanderpump people don't drink
as much as people think that they do if
that makes sense like I never really
watched the Housewives but I happened to
catch the end of the New York housewives
like I think they were playing like the
end of last season like and then the
reunion or something and they were
recapping their Mexico trip I I was
think these people drink ten times as
much as the banter from people like you
know when they were all like naked in
the pool oh my god yeah I was like it
was like hard to watch it was it what
are you doing yeah and it's hard to
watch like people have conversations
because it's like whenever like I know
if I
that level like I don't even want to
remember what I said let alone rewatch
it yeah oh my god no it is like I'm very
parent like anytime I've been to like
Katie and Schwartz's bachelor
bachelorette party in New Orleans and it
was like I rarely film like for several
days in a row and I was so conscious of
don't drink too much don't drink too
much because I would be so paranoid if I
got drunk on camera right now I was like
wait to eight months I wouldn't come out
I couldn't do it I would I would I would
move out of the country and no I would
be so nervous
that's so true I'm sure they might've
like maybe you get like desensitized to
anything I think I think that they do
yeah I think they don't care
yeah like Kristen falling I I feel like
oh my god I was I was so secondhand
embarrassed for her but like it was that
was not good I couldn't so she just like
she doesn't seem to care
no I mean I think she just knew she
thinks she was like it wasn't a cute
look but I don't think that I know so
fallings not the worst thing I like you
could do yeah could happen I do that
sober so right I snapped my ankle last
weekend but I was I had drank but snap
doesn't like broke my cousin twisted
like I was wearing heels I was four
knighting and then the leg I was
fortnight hang on just like Ricky's
fortnight when I'm bear it's like what
they kill that thing okay okay you're
doing that in heels I was doing anything
else at Coachella for Jay Bell there
you're a hero
thanks pressed I mean and I got injured
but I feel like if I don't get injured
like it wasn't successful we can you
know um you're looking at Hathaway
totally no I have a new respect for Anne
Hathaway because I didn't know I had so
much in common with her and that was
such a relatable thing for her to say
right a PR move cuz people don't like
her right know people don't like pizza
like a Gwyneth Paltrow thing I think so
or it's like a Taylor Swift thing where
it's like at the peak of her pain she
was just like it like not palatable yeah
I never loved how bad she couldn't
Paltrow is know anything like I it makes
me happy and and knees knees like
Gwyneth Paltrow I was like who she is
like she's a cult following people love
her people are always gonna like make
fun of her and goop but I don't think
that she cares but like a P like Anne
Hathaway and Taylor so if like really
care yeah I feel I can sense yeah I can
sense it because they then they change
when they get like negative feedback
then they change who they are and why do
things completely differently when it
doesn't
that's how I know I love when she told
the person at the yoga studio that she
invented yoga do you know that story no
I don't know that I don't want to recap
it wrong but I guess she was in a yoga
studio and I think the girl checking her
in was some like so have you done yoga
before like doing what normal people do
in a yoga class and she either said like
honey you wouldn't have a job if it
wasn't for me or I invented yoga or I
made it famous something I was like
that's so amazingly pitching that's so
and maybe true I don't know I don't do
yoga I don't know the origins and she
didn't know she she did not invent yoga
an entire culture of people did not her
okay yeah someone should tell her okay
next story sophie turner says she
considered suicide over gameofthrones
criticism this story is really sad so V
Turner says her Game of Thrones Fame
negatively affected her while growing up
in front of millions of viewers she was
on dr. Phil's podcast apparently as a
podcast and he's getting premium guests
and she said I was so in love with
working on Game of Thrones I couldn't
believe I was going to get paid for it
everything was incredible it only
started to go downhill I think when I
started to hit puberty and really
puberty at like 17 and my metabolism was
slowing down massively and I was gaining
weight and there was the social media
scrutiny and everything and that was
when it kind of hit me she said she
suffer from depression for about five or
six years the biggest challenge for me
is just getting out of bed and getting
out of the house and learning to love
yourself is the biggest challenge I
think when her friends were all going
off to college she remained at home to
continue working on the hit HBO series
the combination of living at home with
her parents her friends going to school
on the rise of social media however made
her feel alone I had no motivation to go
to do anything or go out even with my
best friends I would cry and cry and cry
eventually her depression became too
much and she started contemplating
ending it all quote it's weird to say
it's weird I say I wasn't very depressed
when I was younger but I used to think
about suicide a lot when I was younger I
don't know why though maybe it's just a
weird fascination I used to have but
yeah I used to think about it I don't
think I ever would have gone through
with it I don't know and now she says
she loves herself more than she used to
now she said I don't think I love myself
at all but I'm now with someone Joe
Jonas who makes me realize I do have
some redeeming qualities I suppose it's
really sad
it's really sad but like I'm glad it has
a happy ending because she seems so I
mean nothing's ever like what it seems
but she really seems like so happy and
confident and sure of herself yeah and
everyone goes through self-doubt but I
really do feel like she's better than
she's ever been
yeah I like when celebrities that come
out with stories of like their
depression and stuff because I think
that people like regular people who are
depressed I think they look at
celebrities I think like God they was
just so good about themselves so when
she says stuff like that it's like it's
think it's nice for the rest of the
world to hear right and then it's also
nice for like the people who were being
[ __ ] on social media
like I stopped doing that I know and
it's like I feel like sometimes people
even like good hearted people are like
well not trolls like you find yourself
like maybe I wouldn't comment on her
Instagram I maybe I've set a comment
offhandedly like oh like sunset like
yeah yeah actually I don't even recall
her ever like looking different or
having gained weight yeah but you it
makes you like check yourself like do I
do that like yeah I tried no I'm try not
to do that I try not to do that too but
we're all like because it's even like a
little like you posted something that
like I don't know I just mirrored that
um like synchronized you posted the
thing that I was gonna be on the show
and most people said nice stuff but one
girl was just like the worst and I was
like did you have to write that tell you
know I wanted to respond and be like
right I was like I'm just gonna
instigate but I'm like I I would never
know out of my way just to say something
mean like that totally and then
sometimes when like someone's being a
hater and they get like a response from
the person like it actually is pretty
shocking for them and it might have like
because you when you do something that
you don't expect that the person's gonna
see and then they're even like a real
person that yeah that's gonna care yeah
I don't even I don't have like a million
followers like I'm probably gonna see it
like you judge
you're just bullying me right I don't
really care but no it's so true though
and like and so I'm sure even like that
person like thinks of themselves as a
good person but it's like don't
contribute in any sort of way and if you
don't have something nice to say don't
comment in on Instagram yeah that's
really L your friend tell you talk
behind my back like normally
yeah do that totally um okay fifth story
some exciting news dropped this morning
Beyonce unleashes the surprise
homecoming album alongside Netflix
concert doc beyonce knowles carter has
done it again with the release of her
Netflix concert film queen base
surprised the world again by dropping an
unexpected homecoming album a live
version of the same Coachella concert
performance featured on Netflix knows
made the secret albums
her thing in 2013 and kept that
tradition going with her lemonade album
and everything is loved the latter she
created with husband jay-z so homecoming
the album features recordings of crazy
and love freedom formation bow down
drunken love and lose my breath
featuring the Destiny's Child's that's
Kelly Rowland and Michelle Williams and
more from when she delivered a
jaw-dropping 2018 Coachella set exciting
so when I do see her performance live at
Coachella know I wasn't there last year
and when I first read the story I
thought it was like a new music in
addition to a documentary but it's just
like live it's kind of like Greatest
Hits live okay but that's like just what
we need I feel I'm actually I'm not like
the hugest Beyonce fan but I would love
to see that performance I'd totally
watch it me too she's she's one of the
greatest performers of our time I will
definitely watch it that's like I love
concert DVDs I mean like you know I
think it was Hannah Montana who did it
first but everyone who follows or might
have been the Jonas Brothers I forgot
who pioneered this industry but I'm so
grateful for it it's the best thing to
have on when you're getting ready or
like and to have the album that comes
with it it's just it's exciting it's
cool yep like now I'm realizing it's
probably not on Spotify and therefore I
probably won't because it'll be on tidal
it looks like on title the Jay Z's
streaming power I know I had one let me
check ratify I live under a rock it's
fine it's fine it's must be nice site
it's so weird that some people aren't so
like I was Donham it sounds bad if I I
stand corrected
interesting like I went to a Garth
Brooks concert recently and I really
wanted to listen to his music beforehand
you can't find it any I know he's one of
the few that has like held out and not
join streaming services which I mean he
seems to still be doing well and it's
not hurting him and even though you know
you need to like evolve organizations
picking up the yeah she has a cooking
show but he should be able he should
just sell his albums digitally like you
can buy it whole album you don't have to
stream it but he should sell like his
albums on iTunes even I think that's
weird yeah I think it's weird to like
don't you want it like especially for
new music fans I'm not if I don't
already know Garth Brooks like I'm and I
want to find the like theater or the
strategy is behind that I think it's
like an integrity thing where it's like
I'm sure
digitally produced music like isn't as
good of quality and he just like won't
make like water down his music like that
there's no way you would remember this
cuz you're a little younger than me but
do you remember when he was Chris Gaines
for a hot second no but I I think I did
a Trivial Pursuit where that was a
question
strangest thing it was super top stars
he was like I was there he goes me he
was like a depressed
yeah like rock star with like one hair
in front of his face with like it was so
weak so weird that is like I can't
imagine how that pitch went to his
record company or they pitched it to him
like here's what we're gonna do you're
gonna be a rock star we're gonna change
your day like what that is so weird it
was so weird
oh my god it seems like it it seemed
like a crazy mental breakdown no like a
comedic I will I knew that he had done
it from Trivial Pursuit but I didn't
think it's worth the Google search that
is so weird it's it's bizarre strange
man strange people thought that Taylor
Swift was gonna do that like have a
bucket sorry or do the alter ego and
then like state country as Taylor Swift
should she do this pop now no but now
she's just Taylor Swift throughout oh
yeah yeah people thought she was gonna
have like a Garth Brooks moment and like
become a pop star I think she knew
better I think Garth paved the way for
people to not do that I mean it was
really Hannah Montana who paved the way
I'm having a reference but then you know
now these days Erica Jane is picking up
the baton of just living two lives or
sorority and Jane she is awesome have
you met her no do you see the Beverly
Hills women a lot because of like the
crossover uh Kyle Richards goes to the
same lip method like workout class I've
seen her there a few times I see Lisa
you know whenever it going oh right my
reaction was like um you're not watching
Beverly Hills this season but you might
enjoy like the the coming The Reckoning
of Lisa Vanderpump
so she there they're like burn on her
because of like she just did some shady
stuff that way apparently it's like
normal behavior for her but they just
decided it's enough however calculating
the rest of the world like the viewers
like aren't convinced and like they're a
lot of people are taking Lisa side and
I just don't understand I'm just so sick
of her being mean to Kristen it's like
she sounds like a crazy ex-girlfriend I
like the way that Lisa talks about
Kristen is the way that Kristen talks
about Jake I was just gonna say that
it's a hundred percent true it's like
now you're being too obsessive it's
weird like let it go like it needs air
it's even weirder because Lisa's not
Kristen's crazy ex-girlfriend kristin is
the definition of a crazy ex Earl this
is a grown older woman like what why why
do you care it's so it's so weird now
I'm not even Lynn like Ann but every
time I see it I'm like justice for
Kristen like she is very much a cast
member on the show and like she going to
a Tom Tom party like shouldn't even be a
topic of conversation like yeah it's not
like it's so weird and it's not even I
don't even think it's interesting
content hydrate I don't think it's like
wow this really makes the show that like
Kristen's like left off an invite list
it's like no I feel like Lisa's just
constantly trying to dig out Kristen and
like get at her paycheck Kristen texted
me after they filmed the reunion and
Lisa I don't we'll you'll see it when it
comes out as it hasn't come on you know
Lisa does something very bizarre -
Kristen there that Chris Kristen was
literally like I don't even know where
it came from
and she was like genuinely really sad
like I think I like [ __ ] it doesn't
understand like why is Lisa doing this
like it made no sense it came out of
nowhere and I guess like the other cast
members were like do they have her back
yeah totally
oh my god that is so weird I'm excited
for you and what else did you hear about
it I heard it was like pretty dramatic
considering it's not that it was like
the hardest one to film really yeah I
don't know I don't really i mean i
wonder how so cuz it seems like this
season everyone's pretty much on the
same page and like james and Raquel are
like the villains um but everyone else
is really getting along I yeah I don't
know exactly what they thought about
everyone's I know Kristen and Stassi and
Katie argued a little bit about Carter
but oh and but Kristen and Carter are
still together yeah oh you can't I know
I don't know they think I where it's
just like everyday vibrant yeah yes okay
cool
I want like I just want happiness for
Kristen I do too
I just Kristen is the best she's just
really like one of the most generous
wonderful people like well you can tell
even though on the show she I mean I
don't know about editing but she doesn't
always get like this she doesn't always
look come off the best on the show you
can tell that she's a good person and a
good friend me from her relationships
with other people in the way that other
people
stick up for her and that she really
gets along with everyone in the group
even when like no one was friends with
scheana like she was sometimes with
scheana so I think that says more about
her than like the things that she does
or its other people first and defends
other people to her own detriment
like yeah and I think that I think that
that's part part of the reason to why
she butts heads with Lisa it's like or
even my production it's like Kristen if
she thinks something is unfair for
someone else she'll like really fight
for it and I think it era Tate's
production oh for sure and it's like and
I'm sure in this world that you have to
pick your battles and like you first
shalt like battle with everyone or else
like you're on an island so anyways we
have a lot of questions for you pretty
much like Vanderpump related so I'm
gonna I actually I want I always want to
ask people like questions about your
stand-up but it's like the thing about
stand-up and I learned this the hard way
once it's like you can't really talk
about your joke so much because then
when someone comes and sees it totally
it's not there like one time is not
really funny just in conversation like
this one time I was so excited to see a
comedian the first company so that when
he was at Caroline's so I went on
YouTube and I was like the way that you
wanted to listen to Garth Brooks yeah
we're a concert I was like I want to get
amped up I'm gonna watch some of their
stuff yeah and I wound up watching
something that was the exact set that
was the whole show yeah and then I went
to the show and I knew every single
punchline and I was like oh that's my
got that fun you know that's why you
can't record at comedy shows and like
that's why it's like yeah it's so topped
like top secret almost cuz it's like the
laugh is the whole fun of it yeah
totally now and the surprise of the joke
sometimes it's fun to like see something
live though that you really like to
watch like I love like Jim Jefferies
gun-control bit and then when I saw it
live I was like it's it's fun to see it
yeah but sometimes yes it does like it's
like a giveaway where you're like I
already knew it was going right or when
I saw Amy Schumer last summer and so
many of her jokes were from her
monologue on SNL and I wasn't the only
one who saw that yeah and it was like I
felt like I seen the whole thing so wait
you saw her live her you saw her special
I saw her life and she's weird and she
and then it was like she expanded on her
Mont like the monologue was like the
shortened version and then she like
expand on it but I knew any of the
central themes that's strange because
that was so public no totally huh
interesting
it's it's her it was an interesting
factoid um
before I get to questions for you I just
want to tell you guys about third love
because I [ __ ] love it truly for a
big breasted woman inside me to third
love is amazing they have perfect fit
they use data points generated by
millions of women who have taken their
fit binder quiz to design bras with
breast size and shape in mind for a
perfect fit in premium they'll feel yes
the quiz is very personal and will I
think it's really fun it's fun but it
took me a while I was like what breast
shape do I have I was like no it makes
you like another Campari true and it has
more sizes than most other brands they
offer more than 70 sizes including their
signature half cup sizes the convenience
of third love is unmatched you get to
skip the trip to the store and the
uncomfortable fittings an order online
and try at home third love knows there's
a perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering our listeners 15% off
your first order go 2/3 love.com slash
morning toast now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today I cannot
recommend it enough the quality the
comfort the fit I think they are very
flattering they are I feel like they
make me look slimmer and they so much of
like your shape has to do with like your
posture in your bra and like it just
holds it it's it's quite an important
thing and like once women look like once
I learned that for so long I was just
wearing like random bras yeah once I
thought a brother actually fit me like
it changes your game she really does mmm
so can't recommend it enough third love
comm code sass morning totes okay
questions for you where do you stand on
the James verse the group drama I think
most of the stuff that they he's
deserved like he's yeah I mean I was
around a lot when he was dating Kristen
and he was really awful to her like
really he's he's a very I mean he has
like kind of a nice side because he has
this thing about him where you kind of
feel bad formally yet but and then but
you're kind of like but you did this to
yourself right you can't cry about after
you were just horrible to people right
or like if you want to be so sad about
it continue being sad about it don't do
it again exactly yes though always it's
the repetition it's like
season you've what you want to feel bad
for him but then in his commentary he's
saying like awful things still and it's
like you're still that guy not you're
not changing if you felt bad and then
changed cool no Jax I guess exactly and
Jax keep trying to make that point about
how they're different and like everyone
is like falling on deaf ears but it's
like you know I it's it's true
like I always like felt so bad and
wanted to change he just like couldn't
help himself and now he's changed yeah
and I don't consider Jax to be like a
bully and like Jax is more like he hurts
other people because of his own big
demons I don't know but like the
legitimate like a bully yeah yeah
totally
um I wanted to ask you about Tom Tom
because we did a story yesterday where
they're coming out with now like a wine
at like a cocktail brand like also
probably similar to like the under
pemrose a the Sun can trademark the Tom
Tom name for spirits what is the
relationships like Tom Tom and Tom
weren't gonna own it it's just Lisa and
Ken Lisa in their daily trademark but
their it for Tom Tom so like I just want
to make sure they're not like getting
cut out of this deal and like it seems
already in watching the season like I
just want like a little more justice for
them because like it is I guess they
didn't contribute to the restaurant when
Lisa did but like the restaurant want to
be the success that it is it wouldn't
bear their name yeah they wouldn't be
able to do another like Sur pump like
it's no doubt it'd be like Villa Blanca
where it's like it's irrelevant
totally i I think I mean hopefully I
don't know I actually didn't know that
they came out with a spirit line I hope
that they have like a good stake in it
yeah I think Tom guy was a great
restaurant - the food's really good it
looks great and there's been so many
like celebrities there recently it seems
like it went really well are they so
happy Tom and Tom I think so yeah I mean
I think they're really proud and I think
it's just cool that they have something
like for when the show ends and like
yeah yeah it seems like everyone's in
that stage of like when the show even
though I don't think the show is ending
anytime soon but like you have to think
like five years ahead
Jackson Britney with their beer cheese
I'm so excited I just have kids right
away - I think oh yeah so cute are gonna
go to the wedding yeah of course yeah
yeah excited yeah
I just really ship them and I had bare
cheese for the first time like a month
ago and was did you have their beer
trees no because it's not okay yeah but
when it is I don't think I've ever had
it but it sounds good
it's really it just keeps I kind of like
not
cheese with like a little kick yeah it's
really good it's no Mimas yet but it'll
be good um okay so when Patrick dump
Stassi and you went to Mexico with
Stassi
by the way Patrick texted me the other
day really I was like what did he want
he just said like coupled me of my
podcast he like turned it over overheard
people talking about it but I was like
this was just random anyways that is so
random do they talk at all now no he's
so scary like I don't even want to say
that cause like apparently listens to
podcasts yeah what were your plans for
that weekend before Stassi called her
and said we're going to Mexico
we actually had Naomi was new in town
Christine oh for sure Kathryn Dennis was
in town Kathryn would you had flown but
I forget if the other girls were there
too
Kathryn had flown to LA specifically to
visit it for like the first time and
hang out with us and I felt really
responsible for and we were actually at
lunch at the Polo Lounge and Stassi like
called me right before we got there and
she was like I think you need to come to
Mexico with me and I was like okay and I
was like woah what do I just ditch
Casper don't know what to do now I feel
bad so yeah that was the plans that
weekend damn yeah Kathryn got screwed
what are your thoughts on Kristen as a
travel buddy like would you travel with
her again we were just touched yeah
she'll be fine do you have she gotten
better truly has she figured yes she was
when we went to Nashville for her
birthday I think Europe for some reason
really freaked her out
but I mean she was just went to
Australia about that long ago with
Carter and I think she was fine oh
that's a big tray yeah I think that
she's gun shy now to go with like like
uh in a few weeks I'm meeting up with
Stassi Katie brittny and Lala and Paris
and I feel bad that Kristen's not gonna
be there was that Kristen just come and
she was like not like she I think she
thinks she's a burden now because of
what happened I think that I think
everyone's just all paranoid though yeah
I'm paranoid I'm like don't go Christian
for me I'll be fine I mean it was it was
crazy that's what happened I mean that's
so crazy like and no one even really
know like everyone just knows that it
was like it was like a brief psychotic
break I mean it was look
they like Kristen and Katie were sharing
a room Stassi and I were sharing a room
and we had this Airbnb with like those
tiny like Scandinavian furniture beds or
whatever and Katie had to come sleep
with me and Stassi and we were all
literally like we were playing dead like
you do if there's a wild animal about
ready to attack you we were just laying
there like please that her stuff I think
my god I I don't I don't know she was
just overtired I had oh because I was
gonna saying I should figured I like
this source of the I think it was
incredible jet lag and she did not sleep
for the first like two nights like she
she just couldn't walk was so often so I
think she just lost it
that's so crazy it was it was insane did
you always know you wanted to do
stand-up I knew I wanted to be in comedy
and I but what I thought that was was
like SNL yeah this time but I realized
like I just blob stand-up I mean I would
love to be honest no but yeah I'm not
gonna turn it down if it was offered
where was your first oppa Mikan was a
terrifying I actually took a class the
first time I'd so it was like we had a
showcase at the end of the class and I
thought I was fantastic because it was
like I invited all my friends and family
and like they're obviously gonna laugh
and then when I went to my first open
mic after that I was like oh oh I'm not
I'm new okay yeah this is not like I
don't have a built-in audience oh yeah
that I mean that is so scary what makes
her never I don't go to them anymore but
they're never
you're never getting laughs cuz it's
just other comics in the audience
watching you I'm like they're busy
they're on their phone and like they are
not they have no incentive to be like
you're awesome you know yeah so from New
York where does the tour go we go to
Scotland we go to Inverness then
Edinboro then we go to London then
Berlin then Prague and then Paris and
where can people get tickets Rachel
O'Brien comedy comm that is so exciting
and then do you do like another tour you
know I'm the my next shows in Wichita
Kansas like a couple weeks after that
and then I'm just doing like dates have
one in Seattle coming up to it yeah
that's cool do you like doing like being
in the u.s. are doing international
shows I mean I just love being in Europe
yeah I feel very my snowsuit travel yes
I feel like I can drink wine and eat
baguettes for lunch
ooh speaking of lunch welcome to lunch
time you're welcome thank you so much
for joining us
fine I hope you have a great show
tonight and you safe travels Kristen
shows up I wish you well I hope I wish
you would yeah like you can't improve if
you don't give it another shot
there you go anyways we will be back for
you tomorrow thank you so much for
tuning in everyone can follow you at
Rachel and O'Brien reads like Rachel no
Brian um it's not it's I think we've had
a middle dirty Columbus yeah but it was
like I didn't know people thought it
they think it's like they were like oh I
just thought it was like a funny exactly
that's what I know it's just my middle
initial oh my god that's so funny I
thought it was just like comedy Rachel
no Brian I'm Jackie O problems you
always know where to follow me and have
a great day everyone thanks again we
will see you tomorrow thank you
you